When using Path Tracer, keep a few things in mind about using skylights.
First, the skylight capture is only visible when real-time capture is enabled.
For higher quality renders, increase the skylight capture resolution beyond what is typically
used for real-time playback.
Setting the resolution to 2048 or 4096 should be a good starting point.
If you're not using real-time capture, make sure your skybox or skysphere provides the
sky's proper visual representation.
Also, the skybox or sphere should have the material's Is Sky flag enabled in the material
settings, otherwise the lighting will be double counted, which introduces extra noise.
Finally, your sky geometry, the sphere or the box, should not cast shadows, or it can
block light contributions from both the skylight and the directional light.
You can disable shadows on the geometry by unchecking the Cache Shadow in the Assets
Detail panel.
The skylight can also capture lighting contributions from the sky atmosphere and volumetric cloud
systems.
To do this, simply enable Real-time Capture on the skylight.
Because these features rely on the skylight's Cubemap capture, their visual quality depends
directly on the skylight cubemap resolution.
Higher resolutions mean cleaner, more accurate skylighting.
Note, when Reference Atmosphere is enabled in the post-processing volume, the sky atmosphere
lighting is calculated volumetrically, providing far more realistic results.
In this mode, any skylight in the scene is ignored since the atmosphere itself handles
all sky illumination through directional lights and local light sources.
Finally, Path Tracer represents the planet as a large sphere, ensuring accurate ground
reflection and realistic shadowing in bounce light across the sky.
In this next section, we're going to cover a few pro tips to keep in mind when using
Path Tracer.